Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Joche, die Achtelfinalspiele starten und ich spreche dazu mit Peter Ahrens von Spiegel Online. Peter, einen wunderschönen guten Tag.
Hallo.
Sehr schön. Der nächste Journalist, der in Frankreich sitzt und mir von vor Ort berichten kann. Ich freue mich sehr, dass das geklappt hat, trotz deines engen Zeitplans.
Ja, heute an Fußballfreien Tagen funktioniert das ganz gut. Und ja, insofern hat das gut geklappt.
Jetzt hast du mit dem ersten Satz verraten, dass es aufgezeigt ist.
Als ich das Wort Fußballfrei gesagt hab, fiel es mir gleich wieder ein. Ich sollte einfach nicht zum Fernsehen gehen, aber die Gefahr besteht auch nicht.
Alles gut, wir haben dieses Gespräch vorher aufgezeichnet vor der Sendung. Nein, also wir nehmen tatsächlich am Freitag auf und ihr werdet das Ganze aber erst am Samstag hören. Das macht es für uns umso spannender, ob wir mit allen Prognosen richtiglegen, Peter.
Heute Abend kann sich noch so viel ändern.
Ja, heute Abend am Buffet, da werden die entscheidenden Schlagen geschlagen. Bevor wir in den harten sportlichen Teil reingehen, erzähl mal so ein bisschen, wie ist es denn? Du warst ja auch im Campo de Bahia mit dabei, in Brasilien. Was ist denn so der Unterschied zwischen Evian und Brasilien? Die Sprache. Ja, ich wusste es, dass du es sagst.
Auch sonst. Nein, es ist ruhig hier und das ist, glaube ich, die Untertrennung des Jahres. Also in dem wirklichen wahren, einzig wahren Campo war es ja auch noch so, dass zumindest Brasilianer noch so etwas wie WM-Stimmung verbreitet haben, in dem die da mit Trikots umliefen und fliegende Händler Neymar-Trikots verkauft haben und so weiter. Und hier in Evian ist einfach nichts. Das ist die WM-freie Zone. Es gibt keine Trikots, selbst bei Frankreichsspielen gibt es kaum Fernseher in den Restaurants. Und die Leute behaupten dann, wenn man sich fragt, na ja, das Fußball, da ist ja so viel Geld drin, das sagen also die Leute, die haben gern versehen. Das würde ich gerade sagen. Das hat dann auch noch eine gewisse Note. Es ist einfach so, dass man sich schon die bei mir ja baldigsten Vorstände in Ruhestand gut vorstellen kann, wie das so ist, wenn Rentner Urlaub machen. Das sind ja nur noch 16 Jahre.
Ja krass, Peter. Und ist das dann vielleicht ein bisschen sogar wie Urlaub? Denn nach einer langen Bundesligasaison, dann gleich zu einem Turnier mit der kompletten Trainingslage, Vorbereitung usw., ist ja auch viel Arbeit. Ist es dann vielleicht gar nicht mal so schlecht, mal in einer etwas fußballbefreiteren Zone zu sein? Oder ist es deprimierend, wenn man sich die Kneipe suchen muss, in der man die anderen Spiele sehen kann?
Na ja, man muss ja trotzdem arbeiten. Also das macht es insofern einfacher, dass es jetzt zwei Wochen durchgeregnet hat, bis jetzt endlich hier der Sommer eingekehrt ist. Also man hat auch keinerlei Versuchung, das Einzige machen zu können, was man hier machen kann. Irgendwie wandern oder sich in die Sonne setzen, weil es keine Sonne gab. Und Erholung würde ich nicht sagen, weil man natürlich einfach auch täglich natürlich seine Geschichten liefern muss. Und einfach genug zu tun hat. Abgesehen davon ist man ja auch immer nur zwei Tage zwischen den Spielen hier und dann ist man wieder reisemäßig unterwegs zu den Spielen. Also insofern hoffe ich doch noch stark, dass das nicht als Urlaub durchgeht.
Du bist ja ein natürlich nur journalistisch betrachtet alter Hase. Wie schwerfällt dir denn diese Themen, die du da täglich liefern musst, aus dem Ärmel zu schütteln? Wiederholt sich das nicht irgendwie mit jedem Turnier aufs Neue?
Ja und nein. Also man hat natürlich zum Beispiel halt diese Schweinsteiger-Digestion. Da habe ich natürlich das Gefühl, ich habe da schon mindestens zehn Texte drüber geschrieben. Und dass Schweinsteiger jetzt nicht der schnellste ist, da sollte man sich dann auch immer wieder neue Synonyme für langsam einfallen lassen, dass man zumindest sagen kann, man hätte sich da ein neues Adjektiv überlegt. Klar, es gibt natürlich auch immer wieder neue Themen. Also auch nach zehn Jahren Joachim Löw ist ja doch immer mal wieder auch ein überraschender Spieler dabei. Zum Beispiel Kimmich jetzt nach dem Nordirland-Spiel. Und auch die Routine ist natürlich auch wieder ein Thema oder wird irgendwann zum Thema. Besitzstandswahrung, ist Löw inzwischen Verwalter geworden? Hat er die Risikofreude verloren? Solche Fragen kann man natürlich auch erörtern, wenn vieles schon inzwischen eingefahren ist.
Ja, aber haben wir das nicht auch schon alles diskutiert? Ich habe den Eindruck, es wiederholt sich sehr, sehr viel, bis eben auch so ein paar Spielegeschichten.
Klar, also ich meine, wenn man auch spülert, also wenn man sich den Kader anguckt, da sind ja allein im Stamm sechs Spieler von 2010 dabei. Man muss sich vorstellen, sieben Jahre oder sechs Jahre Journalismus über diese Spieler. Bei jedem Länderspiel hat man ja auch irgendwie die Versuchung, eine Khedira-Geschichte zu machen oder eine Boateng-Geschichte. Das ist schon manchmal schwierig, dann immer noch da was Neues auszuholen. Aber ich finde, es geht noch. Also zum Beispiel Boateng, der sich einfach jetzt noch mal wieder neu entwickelt hat und noch stärker geworden ist in Nationalmannschaft, ein anderes Tending hat als noch vor einem Jahr. Also es sind manchmal Nuancen, aber auch davon kann man ja auch irgendwie was machen. Und für 4500 Zeichen kriegt man immer was hin.
Das ist schön, wie du jetzt deinen Job schön anspruchsvoll verkauft hast und auch möglichst teuer. Aber ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, wahrscheinlich wenn du mal eine Kidira-Geschichte machst, da sind auch die ersten zwei Google-Seiten alle lila und nicht mehr blau. Alle links schon mal durchgeklickt.
Noch viel schlimmer, ich muss nicht mehr googeln.
Ja, verrückt. Tatsächlich ist das auf eine Art und Weise schlimmer. Ich hatte ja früher immer so das Ding, ich war ja nicht bei vielen Pressekonferenzen in journalistischer Funktion, aber bei den wenigen, wo ich war, habe ich ja ganz gern geguckt, was haben die anderen aus den Zitaten gemacht und haben sie die Zitate auch genauso transkribiert wie ich? Machst du das auch noch oder ist dir das viel zu langweilig, weil du weißt eigentlich eh, in welche Kerben die verschiedenen Journalisten...
Ich versuche mich eigentlich thematisch immer relativ von den DFB Pressekonferenzen zu lösen, weil natürlich, es hat auch was mit Beidigkeit zu tun oder mit... Genau, also der Satz, der war der nächste, den ich mir vorbereitet hatte. Es ist natürlich so, dass der DFB natürlich auch eine Agenda setzt und darauf natürlich auch baut, dass dann auch alle Journalisten auf diese Agenda einsteigen. Ich will nicht sagen reinfallen, aber einsteigen. Und manchmal ist es dann, dass man sich auch davon lösen sollte und müsste. Also gestern zum Beispiel, also gestern ist natürlich vorgestern, da war die Pressekonferenz mit Thomas Schneider und Markus Soak. Und ja, wenn man da denen auf den Leim geht, darüber noch groß was zu schreiben, dann ist man auch fast selber schuld. Also dann muss man schon, muss man dann schon auch wirklich das Nichts als Thema wieder setzen, weil sonst ist man wirklich heillos verloren.
Ja, da fällt mir irgendwie Michael Ende ein, das Nichts, das die Welt auffrist.
Die Nichtslöcher beim DFB werden größer und größer, das kann man so sagen.
Genau, hast du das nicht auch gestern getwittert? Der DFB gibt den Journalisten den Tag frei und lädt Sorg und...
Genau, weil nämlich vorher kam eine SMS vom DFB. Joachim Hüpf gibt der Mannschaft einen Tag Freipressekonferenz mit Thomas Schneider und Markus Horkers. Auch wenn der DFB solche Vorlagen gibt, muss man sie einfach verwandeln.
Ja, vor allem wer, wenn nicht du, würde solche Vorlagen verwandeln, Peter? Schön, wie wir da den Bogen zur Mannschaft schlagen können. Was ist denn so dein Gefühl jetzt gegenüber der deutschen Nationalmannschaft? Was glaubst du, wie lange wirst du noch bei den Deutschen in Evian sein und über sie berichten? Wird sich das bis zum Finale tragen können?
Also es ist merkwürdig, dass eigentlich jeder und wirklich jeder, ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendwelche Leute bei der BILD gibt, die es anders sehen, aber sonst jeder Journalist sagt eigentlich, Viertelfinale ist Schluss. Das finde ich schon interessant, weil das zum Beispiel bei der WM ganz anders war. Auch da wartete ja am Viertelfinal mit Frankreich und dem Halbfinale Brasilien jetzt zumindest Brasilien auf dem Papier einer der anderen Turnierfavoriten. Trotzdem hat das da eigentlich niemand damals gesagt. Also niemand hat gesagt, naja, gegen Brasilien hat man keine Chance oder so, was sich auch im Nachhinein als richtig rausgestellt hat. Und jetzt ist es auch so, dass diese Demarkationslinie Italien querstrich Spanien allgemein halt so gesehen wird, ja, das können sie eigentlich nicht schaffen. Ich glaube, die Mannschaft sieht das anders.
Ich würde es mir fast wünschen, dass sie es anders sehen.
Ja, ich glaube auch, die sind auch überrascht gewesen über die Kritik aus der Gruppenphase. Manuel Neuer hat jetzt noch gesagt, naja, wir spielen halt Ergebnisfußball und wir wollen Ergebnisfußball spielen. Also wir sind auch gar nicht mehr so auf diesem Trichter sagen, wir müssen hier begeistern. Da sind wunderschön Fußballspieler, sondern sie sind so ein bisschen auf Ottmar Hitzfeld-Linie eingeschwenkt. Spielen auch so ein bisschen einen besseren Ottmar Hitzfeld-Hitzball, finde ich. Und glauben glaube ich auch wirklich, dass sie auch natürlich auch in Spanien 1 zu 0 schlagen können. Können sie ja auch, aber die Skepsis ist doch schon sehr groß. Und das ist natürlich das Achtelfinale Slowakei. Da wird ja so drüber gesprochen, als sei das quasi schon gespielt. Da ist die Mannschaft glaube ich auch sehr erzeugt, dass sie diese Führer in Anführungsstrichen nehmen können. Denke ich auch. Also gegen die Slowakei auszuscheiden wäre schon echt ein bisschen bitter. Gegen Spanien und Italien auszuscheiden wird jetzt glaube ich allgemein, so zumindest bei den Journalisten hier so gesehen, als was jetzt nicht irgendwie in irgendeiner Form ehrenrührig wäre.
Ja, eigentlich ja erstaunlich, wenn man sich überlegt, wie gut der Kader ist im Vergleich auch. Also ich würde sagen, zusammen mit Spanien hat Deutschland den vielversprechendsten Kader bei dieser EM. Und dennoch zieht sich dieser Pessimismus durch die Berichterstattung. Das ist echt erstaunlich. Und gleichzeitig aber jetzt auch nicht nur, man könnte ja auch sagen, wir fahren die belgische Linie und hauen auf den Trainer ein und sagen, warum machst du aus diesem Kader nicht einen Europameister? Aber das macht man jetzt auch nicht. Ich finde auch zu Recht, also was sollen wir jetzt auf Löw einschlagen?
Ja, also ich finde, ja, ihm ist eigentlich relativ wenig vorzuwerfen. Also auch diese Debatte in der Höhe des Kimmichs zum Beispiel, ich fand es auch nachvollziehbar, das Argument zu sagen, wenn man zum Beispiel die Ukraine gegen starke Bügelschürmer spielt, dass man da einfach die Defensive zumacht, so wie Kimmich gegen Nordirland gespielt hat, sollte auch tunlichst nicht gegen die Spanier oder Italiener auflaufen, weil da wären wir wieder beim Nichts-Loch. Das Nichts-Loch da hinter ihm wäre nämlich so groß, dass, glaube ich, da die halbe Abwehr dann versinkt. Insofern, finde ich, hat er bis jetzt eigentlich für alle auch Argumente, weil grundsätzlich ist es einfach so, dass man das Gefühl hat, die Spieler sind in ihrer Mehrzahl nicht auf ihrem Zenit. Den haben sie vielleicht schon ganz leicht, zwar aber schon überschritten. Also wenn man Kedira anguckt, wenn man Schweinsteiger anguckt, wo man dann vielleicht sagt, ja, die sind nicht mehr in der Blüte einfach. Also Schürle, Götze, das war ja auch bis jetzt wenig von denen zum Beispiel.
Was denkst du denn, würden so die entscheidenden Punkte sein, die sich noch ändern müssten, damit vielleicht doch irgendwie im Viertelfinale und vielleicht im Halbfinale reicht? Was sind denn so die Knackpunkte?
Also ich würde schon sagen, die Abwehr ist gut. Diese Innenverteidigung und der Torwart, das gehört einfach zum Besten, was man hier in Europa sieht. Das ist einfach so. Und das ist auch quasi inzwischen schon eine Binsenweisheit, aber kann man ja glaube ich nochmal aussprechen. Und auf den Oppositionen, wenn man da defensiv agiert, mit Höveders und Hektor, ist das auch in Ordnung. Aber es fängt halt bei der Sechs schon an. Und es setzt sich vor allem, finde ich, in der Offensive fort, man sich halt wirklich vorstellt. Man steht da eine Abwehr mit Ramos Piquet gegenüber. Die Spanier hat jetzt so einen Überfluss auf einen Torwart, der jetzt nicht so schlecht ist, also das Castillas-Argument ist auch weggefallen. Ja, wie soll denn Julian Draxler, wie soll sich Schürrle Götze gegen die durchsetzen, in der Form, in der sie sich hier präsentieren?
Im Elfmeterschießen nach 0-0, Peter.
Genau, genau das. Klar, aber wenn man darauf spekuliert als Weltmeister, finde ich, dann ist das schon, ich will keine Kapitulation sagen, aber das ist schon so eine nordirische Denke.
Sehr schön, auch wie du jetzt den Bogen geschlagen hast, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt nicht direkt über die Achtelfinalpartien sprechen. Ja, lass das doch auch tun, wir werden ja sehen, wo es die Deutschen hinführt und wir werden da ja noch einiges zu bereden haben und mal gucken, wie weit wir dann über die Deutschen reden in dem Turnier. Die Achtelfinals, die uns heute erwarten, beginnen um 15 Uhr mit Schweiz gegen Polen. Wer ist denn da für dich eigentlich der Favorit?
Also mein Kollege Rafael Buschmann behauptete ja schon vor dem Turnier, das Finale lautete Polen gegen Italien. Sehr mutig, aber ich finde, von diesem Polen-Tipp muss er einfach bis jetzt noch nicht groß abweichen. Ich finde, die Polen, wird ja auch vergessen, wir haben gesagt, die Deutschen haben noch kein einziges Gegentor. Für die Polen gilt das genauso. Die haben ja nur ein Tor weniger geschossen. Und die sind schon als Defensivverbund extrem stark. Also da müssen sich Schweizer, finde ich, schon sich sehr viel einfallen lassen, um da in irgendeiner Weise durchzukommen. Also ich glaube, dass Tseferowitsch jetzt nicht die Patentlösung ist, um die polnische Abwehr in irgendeiner Weise zu überwinden.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wer macht die Tore?
Nach vorne ist es natürlich schwierig. Man kann immer sagen, da ist ein Robert Lewandowski, aber ich finde ja, so analog zu Torz Müller, der ja auch schon ein bisschen am Ende der Rückrunde begann, jetzt nicht auf dem Peak seiner Formen sich zu präsentieren, war das bei Lewandowski auch so. Also er ist torschützendlich geworden und hat natürlich auch an der Endphase Tore gemacht. Aber zum Beispiel gegen Atletico fand ich ihn jetzt nicht besonders auffällig. Er hat auch Bälle verloren. War jetzt nicht, finde ich, so, dass Lewandowski wirklich strahlt und er ist wirklich auf dem Höhepunkt seiner Schaffenskraft. Und das fällt hier natürlich auch schon auf. Dazu halt noch Milik, der, finde ich, an Kalt-Schnäuzigkeit noch eine ganze Menge dazulernen kann. Ja, natürlich bei Ajax viel getroffen hat, aber er hat ja in Deutschland zum Beispiel diese Szenen, wo er da so ein Loch getreten hat, wo er eigentlich zentral freistand. Und jemand, der wirklich sich in dem Moment fokussiert und eigentlich genug Zeit hat, der macht dann wahrscheinlich ein Tor. Also die werden nach wie vor auch nicht viele Tore schießen. Und das gilt natürlich für die Schweiz genauso. Also ich glaube, das wird wahrscheinlich dann das 3 zu 3 oder 4 zu 4 werden, wenn ich jetzt sage, da werden nicht viele Tore fallen. Aber ich glaube, das wird ein sehr, sehr zähes Spiel.
Na, da haben wir doch alle Lust drauf. Aber es ist ja auch das 15-Uhr-Spiel zum Eingerufen. Wesentlich zumindest emotionaler wird es dann um 18 Uhr. Waze gegen Nordirland.
Ja, man muss sich vorstellen, dass der Sieger im Viertelfinale steht. Das ist schon bemerkenswert, finde ich. Also die Tats hat, glaube ich, ich habe gestern in der Tats gelesen, diese EM sei so ein bisschen die Nordirlandisierung des Fußballs. Sprich, wenn man vor vier Jahren noch so von der Hispanisierung des Fußballs gesprochen habe, sei jetzt so der Gruppenphasentrend gewesen, eben dieses Denken hinten, kompakt stehen, irgendwie vorne ein oder zwei Chancen kreieren, davon einen nutzen und ansonsten wirklich auf einen Torwart und auf eine Innenparteien zu setzen. Bei Wales gegen Irland, wie eigentlich immer, wenn zwei Teams von der Insel aufeinandertreffen, das ist echt total schwer, finde ich, da eine Voraussage zu treffen. Normalerweise würde ich sagen, ist Wales auf jeden Fall stärker, personell erheblich besser besetzt mit Ramsey, mit Bale, mit Allen und solchen Leuten. Einfach viel mehr Kreativität. Und dann kommt natürlich dieses Nordirland-Klischee, Kampfkraft und so weiter, wird dagegen die Waagschale gewonnen. Da tun sich die beiden natürlich auch nicht viel. Also letztlich wahrscheinlich ein 1-0-Freistoß Bale. Soll ich dir das... Abgefälscht am besten noch.
Ich sehe ehrlich gesagt Wales ins Halbfinale kommen. Die treffen auf den Sieger aus Ungarn gegen Belgien. Und egal, wer da weiterkommt, ich sehe Wales mit guten Chancen. Weil die nämlich glaube ich tatsächlich vielleicht so ein bisschen sinnbildlich für das Turnier sind. Und das unterstützt deine These eigentlich soweit nur, dass es nicht Nordirland ist, wie ich jetzt nenne. Aber die machen ja genau das. Die spielen mit einer Fünferkette und einer Doppel-Sechs davor. Und lassen erst mal den Gegner machen. Also das Interessanteste wird glaube ich, wer in diesem Spiel den Ball hat. Also ob die nicht den Anstoß machen und dann liegt der da. Es gab mal früher, bei einer frühen Fußballsimulation auf dem Gameboy, gab es da immer so einen Bug, wenn der Ball manchmal in der Ecke lag, ist keiner der Gegner hingelaufen. Das heißt, wenn man 1-0 geführt hat gegen einen stärkeren Computer, hat man einfach die Zeit runterlaufen lassen. Wahrscheinlich wird es so ein Achtelfinale.
Sowas gab es ja sogar ganz früher, noch vor dem Gameboy, beim Fußballkicker. Da gibt es auch dann die Totenwinkel, wo der Ball einfach liegt. Also es wird so sein. Ich glaube, das wird kein Hin und Her sein und kein offener Schlagabtausch. Dazu steht für die beiden Teams auch viel zu viel auf dem Spiel, weil beide haben letztlich mit dem überstehenden Gruppfalser schon viel erreicht. Sie wissen, sie können einfach noch viel mehr schaffen. Diese Überraschung kann durch das Tableau auch einfach noch weitergehen.
Meinst du, das lähmt die, anstatt sie zu befeuern?
Nein, das lähmt sie nicht, aber es macht sie natürlich noch ein bisschen vorsichtiger. Lähm fände ich, das würde ja heißen, dass sie mit Druck nicht klarkommen. Aber dass sie natürlich wissen, was auf dem Spiel steht. Und einfach deswegen so einfach nicht einfach loslauen und egal, was kommt, stürmen würden, als gäbe es keinen Morgen. Das wird einfach nicht passieren.
Ich glaube, das werden wir tatsächlich bei dieser EM in keinem einzigen Spiel gesehen haben. Das ist, glaube ich, der große Unterschied zur Copa America, die ja auch gerade läuft. Oder auch zur WM. Also dieses 3 zu 3, was wir jetzt erlebt haben zwischen Ungarn und Portugal, war wahrscheinlich das höchste der Gefühle.
Ja, obwohl dieses Ungarn gegen Belgien, ich glaube, das könnte auch so ein ähnliches Spiel werden. Also auch wenn wir da jetzt nicht explizit übersprechen, aber ich glaube, die Belgier werden schon auch einfach anrennen und die Ungarn werden durchaus versuchen, dagegen zu halten. Sie werden sich dadurch wahrscheinlich ins Verderben befördern. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das ein ähnliches Spiel wird. Eins von diesen Achtelfinals vielleicht als Einziges.
Nee, möchte ich dagegen halten. Ich sehe Belgien auch gegen Ungarn den Ball haben. Und dann sehe ich Belgien, wie immer, außerhalb von Kontersituationen nichts Sinnvolles damit machen. Und Ungarn einmal kontern. Und dann sehe ich Ungarn gegen WC im Halbfinale. Wahnsinn, was für eine EM, aber irgendwie finde ich das cool. Das ist so fern von allem, was man sich vorgestellt hätte. Und alle, die sich jetzt beschweren über den Turnierbaum. Es hat ja niemand die Favoriten gezwungen, zweiter zu werden. Und ja, Deutschland wird jetzt ein bisschen dafür bestraft, erste gewonnen zu sein. Aber so ist es halt. Es nennt sich Sport. Da kann sowas passieren.
Ja, also dieses Geheimnis über den Modus finde ich so einfach lächerlich. Weil ich meine, natürlich haben sich die Spanier nicht vorgestellt, im Achtelfinal gegen Italien zu spielen. Aber dann müssen sie halt gegen Kroatien gewinnen. Das wissen sie auch. Also mehr muss man da gar nicht so sagen.
Ja, exakt. So, aber etwas mehr muss man noch sagen zu Kroatien gegen Portugal. Das 21 Uhr-Schmankerl, was wir serviert bekommen. Das ist so ein bisschen das Spitzenspiel in dem Turnier Baum auf der einen Seite.
Ich werde es mir auch angucken. Ich bin da in den Laws und freue mich da auch drauf. Weil ich glaube, dass das wirklich eine total interessante Paarung wird. Ich hatte ja so ein bisschen spekuliert auf Spanien gegen Portugal. Aber ich glaube, dass das Spiel Kroatien und Portugal sogar noch interessanter wird als Spanien gegen Portugal. Weil einfach, es gibt genug Spieler-Persönlichkeiten, die mit dem Ball was anfangen können, die auch Ideen haben. Es nützt, glaube ich, beiden Teams da nicht diese Defensivhaltung in einer Weise aufzubauen, die sie auch in den Spielen eigentlich bis jetzt noch nicht hatten. Und insofern wird es, glaube ich, ein relativ offenes Spiel. Kroatien wird ja total hoch gehandelt. Da habe ich noch so ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Ich sehe die jetzt nicht als absoluten Favoriten. Ich glaube, das wird sehr eng. Also, die können natürlich gewinnen. Aber dass immer alle sagen, ja, Kroatien bei diesem Turnierbaum marschiert durch mehr oder weniger, das wird im Achtelfinale schon eine ganz harte Nummer.
Das ist auf jeden Fall eine harte Nuss. Ich bin mal gespannt. Glaubst du, dieser eine Tag, den die Kroatien mehr zur Regeneration haben, wird eine Rolle spielen? Ich finde das immer sehr schwierig, das als Argument anzuführen. Aber andererseits kann man auch nicht wegargumentieren, dass das gerade für die Spitzenspieler bei Portugal eine sehr lange Saison mit sehr vielen Spielen war. Und wenn es dann die Verlängerung geht, haben wir ja auch im DFB-Pokal und im Champions League-Finale gesehen. Macht der Muskel schon mal zu.
Ja, aber ich meine, Modric, Rakitic, die haben genau so eine Saison gespielt. Also auch Modric bis zum letzten Moment. Der hat quasi dann auch in dem Spiel seine Saison abgeschlossen wie Ronaldo und Pepe.
Ja, ich meine eben, weil sie einen Tag längere Generationen haben. Mir fällt das immer schwer, das zu bewerten. Es wird manchmal als Argumente herangeführt. Ich war nie Spitzensportler, deswegen kann ich nicht sagen, ist dieser Tag tatsächlich so wichtig oder macht das Adrenalin das nicht eben?
Ich war auch nie Spitzensportler, aber ich halte das für relativ unsinn. Wenn es irgendwie von Donnerstag bis Samstag geht, dann zieht das, weil einfach die Reignung total kurz ist oder noch gar nicht richtig eingetreten ist. Aber wenn es jetzt, ich meine, was war der letzte Spieltag? Mittwoch. Mittwoch und Mittwoch, Samstag, das ist für mich halt, das ist für die Profis ein völlig normaler Russ, also das zählt für mich wirklich gar nicht.
Und?
Dazu noch Mittwoch nach Mittag, glaube ich, am 18.00 Uhr, Samstag 21.00 Uhr. Also wenn man schon, dann kann man sogar sagen, da sind ja noch ein paar Stunden mehr drin als nur die drei Tage. Also nein, das würde ich, glaube ich, überhaupt nicht gelten lassen.
Ich bin ja wirklich sehr gespannt, wie sich das Spiel entwickeln wird, weil Portugal etwas eindimensional spielt, trotz, obwohl hinter Cristiano Ronaldo noch mehr kommt als bei anderen Teams. Siehe zum Beispiel Schweden. Aber ich bin, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie die Kroaten das lösen werden. Und ich bin auch gespannt, wie die Portugiesen dieses Spiel angehen. Ich glaube, die waren tatsächlich über die Entwicklung dieses 3 zu 3 gegen Ungarn ein bisschen geschockt. Also gar nicht so sehr über den Spielverlauf, sondern einfach, dass das, dass es überhaupt diese Möglichkeit gibt, dass man mehrfach hinten liegt und die mussten sich ja wirklich strecken, da irgendwie noch das 3 zu 3 hinzukriegen.
Anders haben sie es geschafft. Also man kann natürlich dann auch, also ich habe auch als es 2 zu 1 für Ungarn viel kurz nach der Pause, ich dachte, jetzt sind die Portugiesen eigentlich tot, weil damit wirklich überhaupt nicht gerechnet, dass sie schon einmal Rücksstand aufholen und dann nochmal wieder in Rücksstand gegen Ungarn. Aber sie haben es halt hinbekommen. Und klar, dann hat Rinaldo auch wieder natürlich eine Rolle dabei gepielt, aber sie haben es hinbekommen. Und letztlich war es natürlich so, dass man sagt, die haben schon eine Gruppenphase gespielt, die man tendenziell als enttäuschend betrachten kann. Aber anders als hätten sie auch zum Beispiel das Spiel gegen Österreich so locker gewinnen können. Und wenn es nur mit 1 durch 11 Meter ist, weil die Österreicher, war klar, die hätten bis 1978 spielen können, die hätten noch kein Tor mehr gemacht. Also insofern ist es halt auch immer, ich finde es immer komplett schwierig, Gruppenphasen als Messlatte zu nehmen oder als Maßstab zu nehmen. Da ist halt auch einfach Durchkommen gefragt. Und die Portugiesen sind jetzt quasi Dritter geworden. Das war natürlich nicht zu erwarten, aber haben dadurch ja trotzdem noch wahrscheinlich gut getroffen.
Jaja, die hätten sonst gegen, bis zur 94. Minute bei Island gegen Österreich, hat Portugal noch gegen England gespielt und war in dem Turnierbaum, wo man danach mutmaßlich auf Frankreich trifft und dann mutmaßlich auf Italien, Spanien oder Deutschland. Also ja, die haben es ganz gut getroffen.
Wenn sie gegen Kroatien verlieren, kann es ihnen egal sein, welchen Turnierbaum sie haben. Aber sie wissen natürlich, wenn sie dieses Spiel gewinnen, dann wartet Polen oder Schweiz. Dann sieht es auch schon wieder ganz gut aus, dass diese Truppe, der man das nach dem ersten Spiel gegen Island gar nicht zugetraut hatte, plötzlich im Halbfinale steckt. Das ist natürlich eine Möglichkeit und diese Chancen, die wittern sie natürlich. Dazu sind einfach, da finde ich auch, zu viele erfahrene Spieler drin. Von Nani über Pepe bis Ronaldo, sogar der unsägliche Carisma, der wirklich, finde ich, so unfassbar wenig zum Spiel beiträgt, was produktiv ist. Da kommt, finde ich, bis jetzt fast nur Embolo mit, was so Sachen an alles Falschmachen, was geht. Also insofern sehe ich die aber trotzdem durchaus mit Blick. Clever genug sind die, dass sie sagen können, wir schaukeln das irgendwie. Also würde mich gar nicht überraschen.
Jaja klar, irgendwie, was ist jetzt noch überraschend bei dem bisherigen Turnierverlauf? Und trotzdem steigen wir jetzt endlich in diese Phase ohne doppelten Bohnen ein. Das finde ich jetzt echt schön. Wir haben jetzt so lange gebraucht, uns von sechs Mannschaften zu trennen. Nein, wie viele Mannschaften? Von acht Mannschaften. Von acht haben wir uns getrennt. Jetzt wird es auch mal Zeit, dass da jetzt mal schneller ausgesiebt wird, auch wenn das vielleicht ein bisschen weh tut.
Aber acht sind schneller weg. Wir brauchen nur drei Tage.
Da geht doch auch bei dir wahrscheinlich jetzt so ein bisschen das Kribbeln los. Endlich beginnt das eigentliche Turnier.
Ja, ich finde das ja. Ich finde es nicht, dass man sagt, das beginnt erst jetzt. Ich finde, das beginnt halt schon mit dem ersten Spiel. Da kann man halt auch schon auch ganz viel falsch machen und die Weichstellung in die falsche Richtung gehen. Also dieses Spielen Ukraine zum Beispiel, das Deutschspiel hätte ja auch ganz anders ausgehen können. Und dann wäre ja auch die Panik und die öffentliche Hysterie gleich losgegangen. Also dieses Kribbeln finde ich ist schon von Anfang an da. Und es ist ja nicht so, dass man so ein Spiel wie Deutschland-Ukraine oder Deutschland-Polen, wenn man dann dabei sitzt oder im Stadion, dass man das dann nicht als Chaos-Spiel ansieht. Sondern am Ende kann es zwar unentschieden ausgehen und dann ist es so. Aber man hat ja schon das Gefühl, da kann einem Team ganz schnell der K.o. versetzt werden. Auch wenn er dann auch in einer Gruppe drei Spiele sind halt auch nicht besonders viel. Da ist eine Niederlage schon extrem schwer.
Na gut, dem ist natürlich schwierig zu widersprechen. Ich stelle so ein bisschen an meinem Umfeld fest und an dem, was ich auch in meinem beruflichen Umfeld sehe, dass diese große Euphorie noch ein bisschen fehlt. Also während der WM vor zwei Jahren war ein wahnsinniger Bass um jeden heißen Wind, der im Trainingslager gelassen wurde. Und das ist jetzt zur EM noch nicht so. Und ich frage mich, ob das jetzt vielleicht kommt.
Ich würde fast sagen dankenswerterweise. Weil dieses Euphorie und Hysterie klingt zwar nicht was ähnlich, aber hat schon auch miteinander was zu tun. Aber es ist natürlich so, die deutsche Mannschaft zum Beispiel hat einfach noch kein begeistertes Spiel gemacht. Das Wetter war schlecht und so weiter. Und kam diese Hultz-Meldung. Das gab relativ wenig, was so ein Euphorie auch befeuern kann. So ein 4 zu 0 gegen Portugal im ersten Spiel in Salvador bei 30 Grad. Das ist halt was anderes. Das ist was anderes als ein gezittertes 2 zu 0 bei der Ukraine, wo man wirklich sagen kann, Boateng und Neuer haben dieses Spiel gewonnen. Das sind wirklich die beiden, auf die man sich verlassen muss während des ganzen Turniers. Du hast einen 3er-Pack von Thomas Müller gehabt. Du hast einen 1 zu 0 nach einer Standard und einen 2 zu 0 nach allerletzten Minuten, wo es eigentlich schon egal war. Dass man das Schweinsteiger-Tor dann so gefeiert hat, zeigt auch schon wirklich, wie das es sonst nicht zu feiern gab. Also da begeistert zu sein, fällt auch nicht leicht.
Wir lassen das mal stehen. Peter, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie sich das Turnier noch weiterentwickelt, welche unserer kühnen Vorhersagen noch eintreffen wird und von welcher wir und dann einfach so tun werden, als hätten wir sie nie gesagt.
Genau, es versendet sich ja alles.
Ja, und das ist der einzige Grund, warum ich täglich aufnehme tatsächlich, weil die Leute dann einfach ab Folge 10 nicht mehr wissen, was ich in Folge 1 gesagt habe. Und das ist ja irgendwie auch ganz angenehm. Peter, ich danke dir sehr herzlich. Ich kann allen hören und empfehlen, folgt ihm bei Twitter, add Peter-Ahrens und lest jeden seiner Texte bei Spiegel Online, den er immer ohne zu googeln aus dem Ärmel schüttet.
So sieht es aus.
Peter, vielen Dank und viel Spaß noch in Frankreich. Und wir, liebe Hörer, hören uns dann morgen wieder und dann reden wir auch über das deutsche Achtelfinale. Bis dahin wünsche ich euch eine gute Zeit.